les pays qui n'auront pas vacciner 60 %
de leur population d'ici la mi 2010 22
vont enregistrer des pertes de pib
totalisant 2300 milliards de dollars
d'ici 2025 c'est le constat que l'on
retrouve dans un rapport de d'economist
intelligence unit les pays plus riches
en bleu sur cette carte notamment le
canada les etats-unis seront vaccinés en
2021 ou 2022 alors que les pays
africains devront attendre au moins dû
1023 peut-être plus tard également vous
le voyez en rouge sur la carte avec nous
ce soir agathe deux marais directrice
des prévisions mondiales a dit kan nommé
center de jonsson et elle est à londres
bonsoir madame démarrer bon ça alors
dites nous quel est l'état de la
situation qu'est ce que vous avez
évaluer exactement
alors en fait chier quand l'avastine
suite nous avons créé un modèle qui
regroupe des prévisions pour deux
paramètres le premier par averses et le
calendrier de vaccination pour 200 pays
dans le monde que l'on vient de voir sur
la carte sur les écrans et le deuxième
paramètre en fait ce sont des modèles
qui prévoit le pib dans ces 200 pays est
ce que nous avons constaté c'est que les
pays comme vous le disiez qui n'auront
pas vacciner 60 % de leur population
d'ici mi 2010 22 vont perdre total de
1300 milliards de dollars en fait
comment est ce qu'on a fait le calcul on
s'est posé une question très simple on
s'est demandé à quoi ressemblerait
l'économie mondiale si tout le monde
vacciner tout de suite et en fait le
constat c'est que la différence entre le
pib virtuelle si tout le monde vaque
signé tout de suite et le pib réel ce
qui va réellement se passer ce sont ses
2300 milliards de dollars qui vont
manquer à l'économie mondiale à cause
des délais dans la vaccination et cela
s'est notamment dans les pays émergents
donc c'est en quelque sorte une mesure
de l'inégalité vaccinale que nous
connaissons présentement dans le monde
absolument c'est une mesure les effets
de l'inégalité vaccinale que l'on
connaît présentement dans le monde
puisqu'on voit notamment que c'est les
pays émergents qui vont supporter ses
2300 milliards la de coûts donc quand
vous êtes les pays émergents pour être
précis quelles sont les régions qui sont
vraiment les plus touchés par cette
inégalité vaccinale vous parlez de payer
émergents dans la carte on voit bien sur
le continent africain également oui tout
à fait il ya deux façons de voir cette
question la première façon c'est de le
regarder en valeur absolue alors en
valeur absolue ce sont plutôt les pays
asiatiques qui vont enregistrer des
pertes de pib d'environ 1700 milliards
de dollars donc quasiment deux tiers des
pertes mondiales la deuxième façon de
voir les choses c'est en valeur relative
et là on voit que les pays africains
quand vous venez de le mentionner seront
particulièrement touchés puisque leur
père sera équivalente à environ 3% du
pib des pays d'afrique subsaharienne
quels sont les risques économiques de
cette inégalité de cette inéquité en ce
moment alors les risques économiques
sont multiples le risque le plus évident
en fait c'est d'alimenter la pauvreté à
l'échelle mondiale à cause de cette
iniquité vaccinale puisque nous allons
voir que les pays en voie de
développement qui peine à vacciner leur
population vont en fait mettre plus de
temps à rebondir après les récessions
qui ont été enregistrés notamment
l'année dernière mais ce ne sont pas les
seuls risques je dirai au delà des
risques économiques on a également des
risques politiques des risques sociaux
davis géopolitique donc quand même des
risques extrêmement importants qui vont
durer d'antan comment on en arrive là
parce que vous savez chez nous on est
presque à 80% pleinement vacciner le
royaume-uni la france les états unis les
niveaux d'accès nations sont quand même
élevé alors comment l'expliquent cet
écart de vaccination comment on en
arrive là
alors je dirais que c'est un ensemble de
facteurs qui explique les écarts de
vaccination entre les pays riches que
vous avez mentionné comme le canada et
les autres pays qui peine à vacciner le
premier facteur c'est la production
puisque la production en fait de vaccins
peine à répondre à la demande mondiale
actuellement notamment parce que les
pays les plus développés ont accaparé
une grande partie de la production
mondiale en tout cas cette année en
précommandant des vaccins mais la
question de la production fait ce n'est
pas le seul problème il ya d'autres
soucis la logistique par exemple je suis
mené des vaccins dans les pays émergents
c'est extrêmement difficile tant pour ce
qui concerne les transports que pour ce
qui concerne le respect de la chaîne du
froid on a également un manque de
personnel médical pour administrer les
vaccins dans un certain nombre de pays
émergents une hésitation à se faire
vacciner également dans beaucoup de pays
en voie de développement on retrouve des
forts niveaux d'hésitation pour se faire
vacciner par exemple en ukraine au
vietnam ou également en inde et enfin
finalement la question du financement
puisque est bien évidemment un certain
nombre de pays en voie de développement
elle a financé les vaccins comment faire
pour combler l'écart entre l'axé dans
l'axé aux 20 au vaccin est ce que c'est
possible de combler cet écart de réduire
cet écart
alors je dirais que les pays en voie de
développement qui voudraient vacciner
leur population de plus vite possible en
fait tous trois options la première
option c'est comme axe come-back c'était
c'est toujours le mécanisme de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé pour
expédier les vaccins dans les pays ayant
un pays en voie de développement mais ce
qu'on voit actuellement c'est que comme
axe pour l'instant peine à répondre à la
demande puisque kovacs va expédier que
210 millions de doses de vaccin pour
l'instant aux pays à faible niveau de
revenu moyen niveau de revenu sur un
objectif cette année qui était quand
même de 1,9 milliard de doses de vaccin
donc on est très très loin de remplir
les objectifs la deuxième possibilité ce
serait vite dons de la part des pays
développés tels que le canada le
royaume-uni les etats-unis et là on voit
en fait qu'il ya un grand écart entre
les promesses qui sont faites par les
pays riches par exemple au g7 il ya eu
une promesse de livrer un milliard de
doses de vaccins et la réalité la
réalité sur le terrain c'est que
seulement une fraction de ces deux
arrivent réellement dans les pays et
enfin la troisième possibilité c'est de
se tourner vers la russie ou vers la
chine qui ont un mot diplomatie
vaccinale agressive et on voit des
vaccins dans les pays émergents et pour
un certain nombre de pays émergents à
l'heure actuelle c'est la seule
possibilité c'est ce que nous verrons
agathe de marais merci beaucoup merci à
vous
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i see her dit